[Music]
Paul thank you so much for coming on the
show dr. small small D knows how you say
your name yeah that's right perfect
so you say in the natural selection of
bad science that science is not merely a
a system free of incentives that it has
has forces at work that make people act
in certain ways or there there are
forces that affect the system and you
say that's leading us to sort of a
system of bad science could you explain
what you mean by that can you unpack
that a little bit yeah and I want to
just start by saying that it doesn't
necessarily have to lead us to a system
of bad science and I think there are
some areas in which really good science
is being done and good science is being
incentivized but there is enough of a
widespread badan simplifying that I view
this and a lot of my colleagues a few
this is a real problem so that there are
two ways in which incentive shapes
behavior the one is the one I think is
more obvious that there are clear
incentives scientists are rewarded for
publishing for getting grants for
getting their papers and their work in
high-impact journals for getting news
coverage etc and so you can imagine
people will strategize will say I'm
gonna strategically change my behavior
because I see what's being rewarded and
I'm gonna do that and that's a problem
but a more insidious problem that I
think fewer people recognize is that
even if you don't have that even if you
can if there's enough shaming or people
just have good enough intentions that
they're not really doing that probably
some people are doing it but maybe maybe
it's not that many if the incentives are
still there then over time everyone can
still have you know perfectly good
intentions and say I'm gonna do my best
but the people whose best involved may
not say less rigorous work and getting
more papers out
doing less rigorous work and over hyping
the results or interpreting it in ways
that let's say are less have less
integrity but you know get the headline
they're gonna get rewarded they're gonna
get the better jobs they're gonna get
more grants they're gonna attract more
students their students are going to
copy their methods and those methods are
going to propagate that lead to worse
results more false positives when your
false discovery is less reproducibility
right and what you're really talking
about is sort of an evolutionary force
acting upon science or saying look
there's variation in the level of
scrupulous behavior and how we reward
that behavior affects how many basically
you could think of like children of that
professor or offspring of that professor
get producing you're saying right right
now or in some incentives we're giving
we're rewarding sort of less scrupulous
behavior and those professors get more
grants more funding and they get more
students under them and those students
are copying those results am I getting
that right or those methods yeah so I
want to point out that it's not that
scientists are awarded only for
publishing papers but it's the cute part
of it and you know different field will
vary on the extent to which this is a
serious problem but I think it is
widespread so if you come action we're
used to thinking of evolution in terms
of acting on jeans and on biological
species that die and reproduce what
culture also evolves right and you know
Darwin lay it out you don't need genes
for evolution they're just you just need
three things right you need variation in
a population you need the things that
vary to be heritable to be able to be
passed down from one individual to
another and you need the selection so
that variation matters in the extent to
which those traits are passed down and
anything that has those properties is
subject to natural selection and
so any cultural treat where there's
variations of scientists vary in their
methods there is heritability in which
you know different methods get passed
down so students have advisers who they
learn from professors who have
influenced they spread their methods
through their papers through their
seminars through their lectures and
there's collection there's a lot more
people who get P it using the sciences
who want jobs then can have them and
that there so there's bottleneck and
selection through the bottleneck is
non-random Hey and there's you know so
the question is then what are the traits
that were selecting for and what are the
traits that were selecting against
correct I think I think this is one of
my big problems because one thing you
talk about is that any any quantifiable
metric once it's being sort of used and
people realize that it's being used
let's say it's like getting attention
grabbing headlines well it gets
corrupted because then people just focus
on well I'm just gonna do that and I I
think this is where there seems to be
sort of an intractable problem because
whatever we select for is gonna be able
to be gamed to some extent do you have
any ideas or solutions in this sense
because it is a very real problem that
there are too many PhDs not enough
faculty positions not enough funding and
so we have it feels like we have to
select for something maybe and I want to
get your thoughts on that I know you
actually are in favor of like a modified
lottery funding thing but I just want to
hear what you have to say about that yes
so well I'll say we just start out by
saying the things that can lead to these
problems are selecting for you know
individuals who can publish lots of
other papers in high-impact journals and
get press coverage you get grants and on
the surface that doesn't seem like a bad
thing right we want you know we want my
are scientists who are productive you do
a lot of
no actually produce work we want to hire
scientist whose work is impactful that
gets cited a lot gets you know is
important enough to be in high impact
journals and get press coverage the
issue is that if we use the measure of
how many papers the impact of those of
the journals are published in how many
grants right
these are proxies and proxies can be
gained right you're not selecting for
productivity per se you're correcting
for a byproduct that is might be
correlated you think with productivity
but if you're only selecting for that
thing for that measure of productivity
and not for productivity in itself then
you're selecting for any methodology or
any behaviors that can increase scores
on the methodology without actually
increasing effort in other words we're
trying to turn a qualitative metric like
productivity into a quantitative one
something like citation numbers impact
vector or you know number of
publications all of these things and
that those are correlated but not
necessarily completely tied together
exactly there's a sort of a famous quote
in economics called good hearts law
named after somebody named good heart
who wrote this in the 70s just said when
a measure becomes a target it ceases to
be a good measure right you know and I
think it's pretty easy to extend this to
lots of other domains you know the media
being one you know with clickbait and
stuff you select for the media that gets
the most clicks and not the ones that it
you know actually does the thing that we
most want in our media another story no
no no I actually I think you're you're
sort of agent-based evolution which
we'll get to in one second is a great
proxy for a you know a great analogy to
a lot of different areas that's why I
thought it was so interesting but your
your paper it
just you know argue these things on
paper you actually tried to set up some
simulations of like labs and how incent
people function under incentives talk a
little bit about that okay sure um and I
do eventually want to come back to
solutions but let's talk about this
rizal our intuitions are usually bad
about complex systems this is just true
of most complex systems in most people
and so that's one thing and the other is
that language is ambiguous and if I say
this is a problem because when such and
such a thing happens this other thing
then follows and you say well I
interpret what you mean by such and such
a thing happens in one way and somebody
else hears it may interpret it in a
different way and they start thinking
through the consequences and their
conclusions might be different their
logic might be immaculate but if the way
they imagine the words that I say be
different then that leads to conflict or
misinterpretation so I'm a big proponent
in general of using formal mathematical
and computational modeling to really
crystallize is what we actually mean
what we're talking about and this is
this shouldn't be real it's this
shouldn't really be a controversial take
because all mature scientists use formal
models all the time right we use models
of you know the planets and for
astronomy we use models of bridges and
engineering we use models of species in
evolution and of cell behavior and of
neuronal neurons and neuroscience right
because we want to parse down what we
know about things and we can formalize
them in the social and behavioral
sciences things are really complicated
so it's it's actually quite difficult to
produce formal models but it's getting
better and people have been advancing
this area you know
pretty famously for Dyna so number of
decades so I think that when we make a
formal model or something we say alright
this is what I'm talking about
I mean this I don't mean this if these
are the assumptions I'm making so we can
be clear and if you think these
assumptions are reasonable if you think
that scientists produced work and
they're the rate of production is
related to their effort and the number
of mistakes that they make is also
related to their effort and if I'm fun
selecting on rigor and I'm selecting
against being wrong then methods are
going to get better because the ones who
are wrong the most often won't succeed
and won't pass up their methods but
knowing what's right or wrong is
actually not that easy right well the
only way we know is to do scientific
studies and if the scientific studies
themselves are flawed then we have a
real problem and what if we're selecting
on how many papers you can get out
purporting or claiming some result
instead of how rigorous your results are
we end up is a whole large literature of
things that don't replicate and this is
really this came to a head about a
decade ago or less in some of the
sciences in what's now called the
reproducibility crisis in particular
psychology and biomedicine and what's
encouraging is that institutions and
organizations and better practices have
been proposed and implemented not
universally but there is an increasing
effort to try to make things better so
you know why with two of my graduate
students we did a follow-up simulation
study to this in part because we thought
well changing norms changing
institutional norms like selecting or
hiring people and promoting people who
can publish a lot these are really hard
to change so the question is you know
you could say well how
things better oh we just stopped
selecting for you know people who
publish a lot and we spend more time and
after four you know hiring people that
are really rigorous and you can do that
to some extent but it's very hard
scientists are busy not everyone is
perfectly able to evaluate someone whose
work is not in their field right if
you're doing a novel innovative work
it's not necessarily easy for someone
else to know how good it is especially
early so you know we use things like
okay the ability to get work out as one
hopefully not the only but as a proxy so
our question was you know if we can't
change this right away if this is a hard
thing to change are there other things
we can do that can help combat this and
we said well there's there's you know
sometimes called for better or worse the
open science movement has been promoting
is like registered reports where you
submit methods and a research plan to a
journal for peer review before the
actual study is done and so then the
journal sort of agrees if it passes
review if they say these are good
methods they agree to publish the paper
regardless of what the results are and
so this does an effort to reduce false
false discovery false positives and to
publish negative results as well which
is a huge drag yeah yeah and to publish
negative results which also skews the
information content to the literature if
you're only publishing you know an
earlier paper on this that when you have
a lot of publication bias and you're
only publishing positive results then
you get a skewed view of the likelihood
that something is really true and you
know if you allow do things to allow
peer reviewers to be better so you know
there's now more of a movement to if you
submit a paper you also have to submit
your data and you have to submit your
analysis code so that people can
actually check your work in more threads
crazy that wasn't already the case yeah
I totally agree it's crazy that it
wasn't already the case and now more
people are like it's crazy that that
wasn't the case we should really be
insisting on this so our idea we're
saying okay if you can make peer-review
better when if we can reduce publication
bias well this is that can be enough to
combat this sort of natural selection of
bad science and the answer's no
simulations so pretty clearly no it's
not enough it's not it's a good at we
should do it we're in favor of it but
it's not enough yeah incentivizing
replication is not enough right we need
something to directly combat this
selection for publication quantity and
the only thing we found is to have
another bottleneck where the selection
criteria is different that compat sit
and our ideas is that funders can play a
big role here because you know hiring
practices at university levels this is
is a widespread and at norms of a
science in general norms of academia
these are hard to change individual
funders can change their policies a lot
more quickly and if they can focus more
on rigor enough then this can actually
make a lot of headway in combating sort
of selection for poor methods let's
continue talking about funding for a
second that's where you came up with the
modified funding idea right where you
have to reach a certain threshold of
rigor if I'm understanding correctly and
then once you do you're in a pool sort
of like a lottery pool for receiving
that funding is that right that's right
so I be clear the idea of a modified
lottery was not our idea other people
other people have proposed this I you
know we were among the first to model it
it's specifically to model its impact on
reproducibility and and scientific
quality so other people have noted and
used there's some nice game
theory modeling showing that a lottery
would actually be a really good use of a
better use of more efficient use to
scientists time because this is a huge
component I I know someone in Grant's
administration and I've also just heard
either anecdotally or empirically there
are a lot of different reports for the
numbers but it's something like I don't
know twenty to forty percent of a
scientist time maybe more than that I
don't know is grant research writing
yeah so the stats I've heard is about
four four research intensive
universities in the sciences and in
science and engineering the amount of
research time spent on grants is about
20% in biomedical sciences and soft
money jobs where their salaries are paid
by grants it's over fifty percent so for
the for the audience that just on the
basis of trying to get all these grants
you are using up 20 to 50 percent of
your scientist time and this is why sort
of this lottery idea might be useful
right that's right I mean should be fair
you know not all that time is wasted
right obviously it's not wasted if you
get the grant but also you know part of
it is doing research and fine-tuning
your your scientific proposals your
hypotheses how are you gonna hear your
study design means and that's important
but it's still a ton of time and a lot
of it is just bureaucratic or just like
how exactly do I write this in the
perfect way that some review are all
rated as highly as possible so I can
compete for this limited pool of money
and so people have proposed that a
lottery would get over you know around
this then all you have to do is pass a
threshold like obviously we don't want
to fund crap or crazy crackpot stuff
right we want to fund things that have a
decent chance of succeeding or I seem to
be well motivated but passed that
threshold of like is this something that
we would in theory fund once it passes
that threshold that seems to be the
method seem to be sound the the team
seems to be good
the policy seems to be interesting let's
just put in a lottery and so what we did
was to say alright let's model this
let's just say you know to get grants so
we compared this with grants just
totally random without this lot without
a test for rigor we compared it to a
scenario where it was the same it's the
same idea is publishing that you know
more prestigious labs who publish a lot
or the ones most likely to get funded
right let's let's back up because I
think we did a focus on that on that
problem real quick the current system is
is that right like explain the current
system for people so they understand
what's going on there's some variation
because funding isn't monolithic there
are many different agencies both private
and governmental that fund science so
that the for the governmental the
biggest ones are the NSF National
Institute National Science Foundation
National Institutes of Health NIH and
the Department of Defense and then
there's lots of private institutions as
well foundations and they all have
different
idiomatic things but basically the idea
is this you sometimes they'll put out a
call thing we're looking for research in
this area sometimes they just have a
general blanket like you know we have
these offices that fund this type of
research so sent us a proposal
scientists get together they come up
with a research idea they write a
proposal they say this is what I'm going
to do this is what we're going to do
this is this is the plan this is why
it's important this is what we hope to
find this is how much money we're going
to need and then those agencies they
read those proposals there are program
officers that are in charge of this to
have some sort of domain expertise and
then they'll often set up a panel of
domain experts to review these proposals
and that will score them on a number of
criteria and the ones that get the top
scorers the ones that tend to get funded
will usually get funded then you know
actually the scores go back to the
program officers and they say okay these
got the best scores can I justify you
know this money going to this but
basically the idea is if you're not in
the very very top scoring France grant
proposals you're not going to get funded
and though how much what is sort of the
marginal cost of investing more and more
time to get your proposal absolutely
perfect so that every pot will Revere in
you don't know who these reviewers are
gonna be right so you have to just try
to think of any objection that anyone is
gonna have and get it in there and get
it sexy and get it use the right words
and not use words that might some review
or might be from a discipline or so
tradition that doesn't like that word or
something like that and it's crazy you
spend a ton time doing this and at the
end of the day for the sort of people in
the top bit it's it's basically random
whether or not you get right I mean
people have done the research where
they've given the exact same proposals
to you know a few different sets of
grant reviewers and the scores like
there's a correlation but the likelihood
given that you know you tend to be and
let's say the top third proposals yeah
the likelihood on any given round you're
gonna get funded and being that top five
percent is so your point is we're
wasting a bunch of time sort of
optimizing this thing that's mostly
random anyways let's save a lot of that
time by making the threshold sort of
rigor and methodology and just make it
what it sort of already is yeah I mean
there should probably be exceptions for
certain things that require continuous
funding but beyond that yeah absolutely
and this matters a lot it matters a lot
for you know what kind of work gets
funded that we want to make sure that
it's not just people who had early
successes and just by chance and then we
they get it they get a grant that allows
them to do a bunch of stuff on the basis
of them doing that stuff that then they
get and get more grants and it's virals
and then the people who were just as
good at the beginning we didn't
better Lee grant good left behind
forever right there and it's like oh
well you haven't gotten a grant so I
haven't proved yourself able to deal
with the grant so we're not gonna even
you grant it's a catch-22
so we'll get to we'll get to solutions
in a second one thing that I thought was
really interesting this is sort of
confusing to a layman like myself but
I'm sure a lot of my audience who sort
of think of peer review as to check to
bad science getting through and one of
the things you say in your paper is that
that's not as true as maybe a lot of
people think can you maybe talk a little
bit about that because that's so
counterintuitive to people who sort of
have an undergrad understanding of
science of like Oh science is just it's
like you know great process process I'm
only discovering truth so let me be
clear like scientist science is this
great process and I it is like the best
way to discover truth but scientists are
humans and they've set up human
institutions and those institutions have
all the kinds of flaws that all human
institutions have and you know peer
review in theory is you know as a
scientist or group of scientists they do
some work and they write it up and they
say this is what we did is what we found
and they send it out and reviewers are
other scientists in a similar field and
the idea is they read it and they check
the methods and they make sure this
makes sense this is and this is done
well and we should publish this notice
something sent that is what happens
but peer review is actually not very
good at weeding out mistakes it's it's
very good at correcting things like
you've ignored this literature that's
really important it's really good at
saying here's an obvious logical error
that you've made in you know make
drawing a conclusion from your results
it's not historically anyway great at
saying these methods appear to be flawed
and not able to tell whether or not your
result is we should believe it and to
some extent it's it's what we talked
about before the fact that people were
sending in papers and not fully
describing their methods not giving
their data you know and it used to be
the aleena before the internet it was
hard to do that anyway right you'd spend
in each day basically trust me we did
this right you know how to deal with it
and it turns out peer reviewers peer
review is just sort of not being
historically set up to catch a lot of
errors
I think peer review is still valuable
and but there's yeah I got into a
conversation with a another scientist
recently where I was arguing that you
know as soon as your study is ready you
should we should use what's called
preprints it was in favor of free
prancing through not bypassing peer
review but saying you know put your
papers up online before peer review and
just let everyone see it and then you
you know you can get sort of community
peer review and someone else said well
that sounds well and good but if
something's on peer review how do I know
whether it's right and I said you have
to read it and also that's true it is
peer reviewed you have to read it like
you can't trust the peer reviewers to
tell you whether or not you should trust
the conclusions of the paper you
actually have to you have to look and
evaluate it yourself and that's that's
what our jobs the scientists should be
now I get it like the public doesn't
have your time or the expertise
necessarily to read every scientific
paper and evaluate every claim they see
in that I mean to be honest most
scientists don't have the expertise to
evaluate something that's not in their
direct field but that is all the more
reason
you know for us to put a higher premium
on rigor and also you know there's
there's a responsibility for journalism
in addition but that's another story
into that that's that's a huge problem
the this the science says tagline just
really gets gets me under the hot under
the collar actually likes so so let's
let's talk a bit about let's talk a
little bit about solutions right because
you know you you have all these problems
you model it look if we have the current
incentives we do it's going to lead to a
really high false positive rate because
these labs keep getting incentivized to
just publish things with it's not so
important whether they're reproducible
number one because reproduce
reproducibility isn't that highly
selected for but it's also doesn't carry
that much prestige and it may have a
hard time getting published so you find
that you find all these things and you
find that like okay labs are you know at
least in this game theory way they
should sort of B's just doing a bunch of
so not shoddy may a little bit shoddy
work I guess what do we do right because
you still have the problem of we have to
measure something I mean like well it
feels like a there's always the pressure
to be measuring something like are we
measuring productivity you know et
cetera
yeah so I mean and this is true of all
industries right hiring is an exercise
in decision making under uncertainty
right we're making decisions about who
we should hire who we should fund who we
should promote with limited information
we don't know everything about this
person and so you know so proxies come
out and you know our sort of current
data-driven world right people are
always like the more you know if I can
if I can have quantitative metrics then
we can do you know we can streamline
things we can make them Universal we can
have these are the standards and
this is a challenge because there are
very good reasons for doing things like
that right when you make things
quantitative it eliminates things like
biases toward what you already know well
if you're already comfortable with it
eliminate it helps reduce things like
gender bias and you know other kinds of
discrimination at the same time it also
allows you know proxies to select for
things that maximize those metrics
without maximizing the things the
metrics are intending to measure so what
do we do this is not an easy question
it's not easy right I you know if there
was an obvious and solution that I was
certain about I would have let you know
um
the one of the things that I think is
most important is for people to be aware
of the problem right if we don't know
that there's a problem it's very hard to
discuss solutions so part of you know
the effort that that I'm involved in but
lots and lots of other people are to
sort of point out this kind of problem
that I feel like to some extent are this
paper the one that you know you
mentioned the natural selection about
science one of the things that he does
is most importantly is just to point out
that this is a problem this is going on
that this is a dynamic that can happen
and it can happen even if individuals
take steps to make sure that their work
is good right it doesn't get you off the
hook it's it's good I support it make
your methods as good as possible but it
doesn't get you off the hook because the
individuals who do you know who have
methods that allow them to game the
system maybe even unconsciously right
one of the things that this kind of
selection pressure can select for is
misunderstandings right if the people
who understand things perfectly well are
the ones who are really worried and take
their time and are really careful and
get a lot of you know negative
results and the ones who misunderstand
use the wrong things and incorrectly
think that they're doing a great job and
get lots of positive results and they
get a lot of that gives some success
then we end up with selecting for
misunderstanding possibility right I
think that's so huge for people to
understand because I think a lot of
people what I'm afraid of is when people
watch this they're gonna say oh well
just scientists need to do better and I
think what you're pointing out is that
there are scientists a lot of them doing
a great job but with when a system is
selecting like this those people end up
getting phased out the people who aren't
paying attention to the incentives of
the game unfortunately even though
they're doing the right thing according
to what we want in our you know
idealistic sense of science they're
getting selected against and and
ultimately they are not the ones who
have all the attention on them have all
the you know funding have all the the
grants and people under them and so that
is such a huge point yeah so this is
this is the major concern that this can
happen well so what do we do one of the
things is we make sure that people are
aware of this and they they take it into
account and the other is that we work
toward you know institutional change
institutional change is one of the
hardest things in the world to do right
it's a massive coordination problem a
hundred yeah there's so many different
players that you sort of have to get all
to agree and adopt whatever the new
standard is whether it be the modified
funding lottery etc yeah so I mean so
things like mattified funding lotteries
and I'm sure other solutions that I'm
not aware of or or or haven't thought of
or just didn't think of right now these
are kind of intermediate things they're
they involve coordination within
institutions but not necessarily across
institutions so changing norms across
the entire and like sort of myth
Mehta institution of academia is just
really hard you know this is the sort of
famous line often attributed to MOX
plonk science Vance is one funeral at a
time it's very hard to get senior people
to change their minds it's not
impossible but it's hard you know if we
can within an institution though
sometimes people can be convinced and
they can do things like okay we should
set up a let's say modify Fleming
lotteries get set up in a widespread
there's probably gonna be a bunch of
problems with that but we haven't
foreseen but that selects for for rigor
in a way that isn't around as much right
now there are other institutions that
are you know are also paying a lot of
attention to this
and so we promote this and maybe we get
pockets right maybe there are little
pockets some field some institutions
some universities some countries that
are more known for rigor than others and
then the question is right what happens
then what happens when you get one
community that published as a ton but it
has a reputation for being not rigorous
and another population that publishes a
lot much less and has a reputation for
rigorous rigor is the thing that we care
about really then maybe the methods of
the radio if that happens right we can
coalesce communities that are
consistently more rigorous maybe this is
idealistic but maybe that's one way for
that kind of behavior to spread sort of
one community at a time and it and it
seems obvious that we would select for
rigor which we sort of can define as
less likely to be wrong about the
finding yeah
I'll say that we can define rigor by its
outcome like a rigorous study is one
where the find the claim or there is the
finding is less is most likely to be
correct right they're always going to be
some error
right yeah absolutely and it's it's the
methodology that really matters in the
end is if you did the methodology if you
got it right you're less likely to be
finding some sort of false positive yeah
I mean there's they're just - just put
this forward there there are really two
components to reducing false positives
one is the methodology and one is the
hypothesis generation where the
hypotheses come from right so if you're
just coming up with crazy things and
you're just or like that seems like it
would be true right let's just test it
things that people without a lot of
training or that don't think things
through very much like let's just test
any nutty idea I have most of those
ideas are gonna be wrong and if you have
enough noise like if your leg and this
is I'm stealing this from xkcd but if
you're like I believe there's a color of
jellybeans that cures cancer I mean it
has every possible color of jellybeans
in the universe over organic it
eventually you're gonna come up with a
positive result because there's enough
noise in the system enough noise in the
system something's gonna be
statistically significant exactly and so
it's not just about reducing noise in
having rigorous methods it's also about
improving the hypothesis generation
because even if you have a tiny little
bit of noise if you consistently come up
with things that are wrong eventually
one of those is just gonna by chance
come up with a positive result and if we
are coming up with hypotheses to begin
with that are right the less acceptable
to that noise are going to be so it's
really these two things together there's
also the problem of heart and right -
like you have your results and then
you're like well this sort of looks like
this is what's happening here so I'm
gonna go hypothesize that and then you
know write a paper about it yeah I mean
I I think of it as a methodological
aspect but you're right it's maybe a
little bit of both so yeah harking
hypothesizing after results are now
yeah is like let's say you know you test
something and you're like the here's
here's some things what does that look
like um now that's actually not a
terrible thing to try to fight like
that's what we do right we try to find
patterns in noise course the problem is
when it's sold as if it's what you
thought was going to happen all the time
right so the the problem really isn't
hypothesizing after results are known
it's it's pretending that that was your
hypothesis before the results were now
yeah all right and that you know so it
presents it as if you were a lot more
prescient as if you had a much deeper
understanding of the system than you
really do I bought us our thing after
results are know if you find a pattern
in the data after you collect it that
you didn't expect that's that's should
be the seed for then more directed
investigation not you know not oh and we
found this ended story
one thing I sort of want you to explain
because again I think this is there are
a lot of misconceptions among people who
know a little bit about science but
never have actually done any work in the
field themselves or have an experience
there's a lot of acquaintance and I
think maybe with a little bit of good
reason because there probably is a
correlation but there's a lot of
equative
good journals with great science right
and I think maybe people don't
understand the incentives that are not
directly quality related that go into
getting into a good journal and I'd love
for you to talk about that yeah this is
an issue and it's it's like anything
else right the the measure becomes the
target so people people have limited
attention spans and we can't read
everything we can't look at everything
you know and so we if we're gonna look
at just a few things it's often we're
gonna check most scientists are gonna
check the the things in their field and
then the big interdisciplinary journals
because of that these big
interdisciplinary journals and other
reasons get a lot of eyes and they also
have very you know things like journals
like specialty journals or run by
working scientists who have other things
going on in their lives journalists like
nature and science are run by
professional editors and their full-time
salary job is editing that journal and
they have dedicated press staff right
that are tapped into so if you have a
study that you think is important a
great way to get attention is to publish
it in nature not just because people
read nature but but also because nature
has a press office that communicates
directly with the press and because of
that and because journals like Nature
and Science are journals that are you
know that make a profit right or they
make money and they high you know they
have to hire staff and they have to sell
issues that means that they really need
to get those clicks and so you know one
thing that if I was you know the editor
of a top specialty journal in a narrow
field and I got a study the real
question is like is this you know okay
is this important and is this right
these are the two questions is this
important and this is right what there's
nothing wrong with that per se all right
what if you say how likely is it that
such and such a claim is right given the
potential importance if it is right so
if this were right how important would
it be now as soon as you start asking
that question you end up there ends up
being the potential to decouple quality
and newsworthiness and to be clear this
is the problem that nature and science
face because they need clicks and so
they're thinking about
how would a lay audience think about
this in terms of importance how would
the press think about this in terms of
I'm sorry right yeah and so the question
is you know get given a certain level of
potential newsworthiness
how rigorous does it have to be to pass
muster yeah right and if these things
are correlated then which you can end up
being you can end up getting is that the
most news pretty things that the least
likely to be true right right right
because because the the most newsworthy
things are the ones that are most likely
to pass muster no matter the risk that
likelihood of Pantera and this is also
true even if this doesn't occur because
if you're selecting on newsworthiness
just newsworthiness right you're what's
newsworthy things that are surprising
and things are some that are surprising
are often things are surprising are the
most likely to be wrong right if you
were like a new study shows that when
you drop things they fall down but no
one would publish that because obviously
that's the case right but if it's like
new study shows that dinosaurs and cats
coexisted that would be amazing and
right and like think of the memes yeah
there's no way that's true right and and
extraordinary claims really should
demand extraordinary evidence it's not
about the news coverage then you worry
well if if there's some chance that it's
true then maybe we publish it and we
take a chance right right it you know
this is it's hard because you know it
comes back to scienter for human beings
and we have human concerns and we I
think I think scientists and I'm biased
because I am one but I love talking to
scientists and I feel really privileged
to be a scientist and get to spend time
working with scientists because I think
that they're really people in general
with very high integrity we're really
interested in
old and interesting and exploring deep
questions in about the world but at the
end of the day we also are human beings
to human concerns yeah yeah so in in
other words the these journals are not a
mere direct they don't have a direct
relationship in other words with
robustness is what you're saying well
yeah so I mean I think that not that
they aren't robust but that they have
other selection methods as well you have
other things they're the editors of all
these journalists all you know have
scientific training and they are aware
of at least some of these problems and
they are doing what they think is the
best job there they can do and they are
taking efforts to check things they're
you know sending their papers out for
review they're trying their best to make
sure that you know claims are not wrong
but they're also humans and they're
subject to selection pressures and
incentives that are not only related to
rigor right and and really this not only
means that if you're a scientist trying
to get into nature in science you might
have to change what you're looking for
because instead of looking for you know
doing just basic research that nobody in
the press is gonna be interested in you
may want to do something that would be
seen as landmark if true you might pick
hypotheses based on you know whether
this is gonna get into nature or you
know science or anything like that
yeah so this actually happens to me when
I was a I was not going to name names
but you know I was I was the postdoc at
one point I did a few postdocs but at
one point and one of the other postdocs
we had been talking about you know yeah
the the job markets pretty tough out
there and he came into my office one day
and he said let's try to think of a
study that we could do that it would be
the kind of study that would get into
nature because if we can get a nature
paper that'll really help us get a job
and I thought we we we're coming up with
the the study based on whether or not
it's gonna and I just said no but you
know that I'm sure that conversation
happens all the time I'm sure it's a bit
like people I'm shocked at the
relationship between like sort of I
think you guys have a lot more integrity
than we do but like in YouTube you'd
sort of hear a similar conversation
going on how can we make a viral video
like how can I make the big thing
instead of it being just about you know
like making the thing you want to make
and then it just becomes as you said
just seeking the metric that people are
rating you by you know and it's hard
because it's these things are not also
not separate right like you want to get
a viral video in part because I can get
success in a land that enables you to do
the thing you want to do right we want
to get jobs as scientists because we
love doing being scientists and doing
this work and we need these jobs and
these grants to do the stuff we need to
do but sometimes you know because these
are incentives that select for different
kinds of behavior right if you're
shaping your behavior and the kinds of
work you're doing that's gonna be more
likely to lead you to a nature paper or
you know to get funded by some
particular agency on the one hand you
could argue well maybe that's good
because those the incentives are you
know these are the the journals that are
publishing the most important work so if
you're likely to get published in nature
that means that you're probably doing
more important work than someone who's
never publishing in nature on the other
hand right importance is very hard to
assess surprise easy right we were
talking about before the show we were
talking about Peter Higgs who I'm
putting in the show how really if it
hadn't been for his Nobel Prize I mean
if you looked at him as a scientist
according to just like every other thing
he had done a lot of people would have
sort of thrown him aside and that's what
he said
you know I if I was doing science now I
wouldn't be I wouldn't be hired
and this is sort of this is sort of the
problem with just measuring people by
their number of publications or by their
you know like if you got in nature or
science or not often time I I don't know
how to say I don't know oftentimes to
the right word but as you say these
proxies are imperfect and we can end up
leaving a lot of really good scientists
at the door and maybe scientists who are
doing the most rigorous work who are
doing the kinds of things that don't
select for just a ton of papers all the
time yeah I mean I think you said it
perfectly there Peter Higgs is it just
is a great example he's just a sort of
the most extreme example but you know
I'm sure you have there's lots of people
who are doing really interesting really
rigorous work and to do deep work also
require some removal right if you want
to do really deep interesting unique
work right who are if you and this is
true of any field not just science but
art and you know literature anything
that involves creation the people who
are gonna be doing the things that are
the most unique and potentially
groundbreaking are probably not the
people who are always moving and
hustling and you know in the limelight
it's gonna be people who at least
sometimes take time and go away for a
while and work in a concentrated way on
what they're doing and if you never have
the time in the space to do that if the
people who need the time in the space to
do that are never given the opportunity
to do that you know what what does that
mean for the landscape of research you
know the kinds of research that we see
and that gets done it's it's not obvious
how to solve this problem but it's it's
I think it's an important thing to
consider
perfect that's gonna be that was very
well said that's probably going to be
your the closing remarks that was
perfect
I mean you absolutely nailed it Wow I
feel really honored I really appreciate
you taking the time no thank you it was
a pleasure
[Music]
you